hallo liebe
heute machen wir einen apfelkuchen und
zwar ein richtig klassischen las ich
eine echte über die stadt dassow haben
soll wollte witzig sein
heute brauchen wir eine richtig leckeren
als klassischen apfelkuchen also nicht
viel creme oder viel schnickschnack ganz
klassisch und einfach und dennoch
richtig schön saftig und fruchtig süß
ich zeige euch jetzt hier zuallererst
die zutaten gut
wir benötigen natürlich apple ich habe
heute sind ledigen um einfach weil die 0
von backwaren ihr könnt aber auch elstar
boskoop oder granny smith nehmen das
sind so typische apple zum backen
außerdem benötigen wir mehl und
backpulver zimmer warme butter eier und
milch auch gerne zimmer war dann zucker
gerne etwas zimt vanille zucker eine
prise salz und ganz wichtig aprikosen
konfitüre damit schmeckt super lecker so
als allererstes kümmern wir uns um die
äpfel die werden jetzt erstmal geschält
und ich habe jetzt zu sagen falls ihr
nicht so zügig arbeitet haltet auf jeden
fall ein bisschen zitronensaft parat
denn die äpfel werden ja schnell frauen
ich garantiere euch es ist nicht so
schlimm wenn die braun werden aber so
sieht einfach schöner aus nach dem
backen und als nächstes halbieren wie
die äpfel und entfernt das kerngehäuse
[Musik]
und jetzt meine lieben ritzen mir die
äpfel ein das hat später eine richtig
schöne optik aber nicht ganz bis zum
boden und würdet ihr sie einen stücke
schneiden also wirklich nur ein drittel
damit wir so eine optik haben und dann
gäb's zitronensaft rüber
[Musik]
so fertig zitronensaft und dann zeige
ich euch den leckeren teig
[Musik]
für den teil verwende ich jetzt die
küchenmaschine natürlich geht das wie
immer auch mit dem handrührgerät ich
gebe jetzt die weiche butter einmal in
die maschine habe übrigens für den röhr
haken aufsatz es würde auch mit dem
schneebesen ausgehen aber hiermit
funktioniert ist für mich einfach besser
weil wir nichts aufschlagen müssen
sondern nur cremig schlagen einmal in
die schüssel und dazu gebe ich jetzt
noch zucker vanille zucker zimt und die
prise salz und die prise salz hebt noch
mal so richtig den süßen geschmack und
wenn ihr keinen sind mögt dann könnt ihr
das auch ganz einfach weglassen und
jetzt wird das ganze einmal ungefähr
drei bis vier minuten lang richtig schön
cremig gerührt
[Musik]
so die masse ist jetzt richtig schön
hell cremig geworden und dann gebt ihr
die eier mithin so schön nach und nach
auf langsamer stufe bis sie sich mit der
butter masse verbunden haben
so als nächstes gebe ich backpulver zum
mehl das ganz kurz um und dann gebe ich
das mit in die masse und die trockenen
zutaten gebe ich gleich bei niedriger
stufe hinein und hier kommt auch die
milch ins spiel je nachdem wie groß die
eier sind müsst ihr dann noch ein
bisschen milch dazugeben deshalb nicht
gleich alles auf einmal dazu gehen es
gibt auch mal die hälfte dazu früher das
um und dann eventuell noch ein bisschen
milch nach gießen
[Musik]
so ihr lieben unser teig ist fertig das
mehl und die milch nur ganz kurz unter
rühren also nicht zu lange und den teig
gewicht in meine vorbereitete springform
hier habe ich einen durchmesser von 26
cm
natürlich geht auch 24 oder 28 cm haben
wir seitdem entsprechen ein bisschen
niedriger oder ein bisschen höher
und hier habe ich nur backpapier auf dem
boden gegeben und die seiten nicht
eingefettet
[Musik]
unser teil ist jetzt in der springform
und als nächstes gehen wir unsere
vorbereiteten äpfel darüber und dann so
ganz leicht ein sinken lassen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der vorbereitete
apfelkuchen in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze für 30
minuten und dann kommt mein absoluter
lieblingsspieler den zeige ich euch
gleich erst nach der backzeit den kuchen
einmal aus der springform lösen und auf
eine tortenplatte ling und ich
persönlich mag dem noch lauwarm und am
nächsten tag esse ich dann ganz normal
kalt wenn du denn hält weil sie jetzt
immer ganz schnell weg bei uns und mein
lieblings schritt kommt jetzt wir geben
jetzt einmal die heiße
aprikosenmarmelade auf den kuchen das
gibt nicht nur unschön glanz sondern
auch so eine richtig schöne fruchtige
note und es passt auch wunderbar mit den
äpfeln zusammen
[Musik]
und das riecht schon so lecker ich sag's
euch der kuchen ist jetzt sofort sei wir
bereit wären am vorabend zubereiten
möchte kann das gerne tun und ihr könnt
euch auch nach der also einen tag später
die mikrowelle tun ist viel mir gerade
so 1
weil ich finde ihn einfach war total
lecker er hält sich drei tage lang
frisch mindestens ich glaube nicht dass
er so lange hält weil da einfach so
saftig ist und ich freue mich wenn ihr
das rezept natürlich nach macht die
genauen mengenangaben stehen hier unten
in der infobox und ich freue mich über
eure fotos mit dem hashtag igs kitchen
auf instagram falls ihr euch jetzt noch
mehr apfel rezepte von mir wünschen
schreibt es nur noch gerne mal in die
kommentare
denn ich bin total im apfel fieber
momentan und ich freue mich natürlich
wenn in dem video im dörfchen nach oben
geht so zeigte mir dass euch gefallen
hat und dann sagen ich bis zum nächsten
mal auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]